trilateral
meeting between the foreign ministers of
russia
armenia and azerbaijan
it took place upon the invitation and
on insistence of that in president of
russia to discuss the situation in
nagorno-karabakh namely the conflict
since day one russia bilaterally and as
part of the means group of the oec
has been doing everything within its
power to stop the escalation and
return these sites to the negotiating
table
as you know we made a joint statement
together with the us
and france that is the co-chairman of
the oic
this group it was supported by the
foreign ministers
and special representatives who are
working
to facilitate the settlement of the
conflict also supporting that statement
after a round of telephone conversations
which
took place in between the leaders
of russia meaning azerbaijan president
putin
invited them to stop the hostilities on
humanitarian reasons
on humanitarian grounds to hold
consultations
on all the issues pertaining to
settlement and on october the 9th and
the 10th you've probably
been there at the time we held the
meeting which
enabled us to reach agreement
you know that was the cis fight was
circulated
we also send it to the oic
to the united nations and we do hope
that the
parameters of this ceasefire will be
adhered to by both sides
of this conflict today we exchanged our
opinions on how to move forward
how to progress it doesn't mean that all
the issues will be settled at once
quickly in one
swift move but we need
to be moving along the road of the
diplomatic process it would be wrong to
be stalling
and as our armenian friends briefed us
today
they are to
be meeting with the co-chairman
of the minsk group of the oic a large
part of our talks had to deal with the
bilateral issues
our political dialogue is very active
it's
very sound dialogue at the highest level
of course we've been
hit by the covet 19 infection we had to
introduce certain restrictions
and yet we have been relying heavily on
televised conversations and
conferences this year
the leaders of russia and armenia had
seven
and some of the officials have met in
person and on the
ninth of october prime minister michigan
visited the
russian comic union summit which took
place
in gerivan and that was a very good
platform for
dialect in the face of this global
pandemic
the covenant 19 pandemic our countries
again demonstrate
that we are too friendly nations which
are ready to cooperate at all times
we will be and we have already supplied
armenia
free of charge equipment and
people madison also we have sent
our military virologists to armenia to
help
armenia out with the copy 19 pandemic
also we are working to return our
citizens back home
those who happen to be outside of russia
during the pandemic
that's one line of our operation today
we have conducted 79.
flies taking back our citizens
also we've seen a record rise in trade
that's 26 now it's 2.5 billion dollars
and even though the global economy is
going down
partially due to the coronavirus
infection this year we have succeeded
in maintaining the existing trade levels
upon
the results of the last seven months our
trade hasn't changed
comparing it to the here before that
we agreed to continue our foreign
relations cooperation will be holding
necessary events in order to build up
momentum and increase our trade
and improve our cooperation and what i
mean
is the work the
twenties meeting of the
intergovernmental commission economic
cooperation which is to take place in
the everyone after the restrictions
are lifted and as soon as we can we'll
be holding the eighth
into regional forum which will bring
together delegations from
several dozens of regions of russia and
armenia
as for humanitarian cooperation we are
very much satisfied with
how the plans of cooperation have been
implemented and that is the culture
plan for 2019-2020 and the
year of griba yadav will be celebrated
in armenia
which is a very good thing to know
also we have six french
universities in armenia a brotherly
university
russian armenian university is also
there in armenia
they all have more than 1 000 students
also we are giving grants 10 million
students to study in russia
annually we are increasing the number of
grants and today
we have over 5 000 armenian students
2 000 of them have received grants to
study free of charge
also 2 000 armenian students are
acquiring vocational education in russia
one of the things today will discuss
international agenda
the whole area of our cooperation in the
international arena
the oic the eurasian economic union
the cis which is the commonwealth of
independent states
we discussed our positions and our
coordination
in the black sea economic cooperation
organization the u.n and organizations
as well as we today discussed
our future plans for cooperation in 2020
2021 which allows us
to be a day-to-day effective in aligning
our foreign political course this has
been very
meaningful to oxendine deeply satisfied
with them
i would like to thank my little
counterpart on the whole delegation
for these talks and i hope that the
results of this meeting will help us to
move even further
improving relations between russia and
armenia creating the atmosphere of trust
and reliable partnership that we need
today
thank you so
very much mr lavrov media
representatives
first of all i would like to thank uh
the russian
side mr lavrov for the cordial welcome
for the constructive
talks we have had quite a
relevant talks regarding our bilateral
issues and about the
regional issues and global international
issues
we have uh reached a high level of the
mutual understanding
regarding all the issues on the agenda
there is witness about the high level of
the partnership and collaboration
between russia and armenia
it's an official visit to moscow that
has been planned
in advance and we are glad that it's
happening
despite all the problems that persist
in our regions
we highly appreciate the efforts
on behalf of russia to in the settlement
of the nagorno-karabakh conflict
and the agreements reached on the 9th of
october the cease-fire agreement reached
on the 9th of october
our relations between russia and armenia
are based
on the corporation that includes almost
all areas of life and
we we have a dialogue on
multi-levels regarding all these matters
and uh mr lavrov
talked about the agenda that we
discussed today and the agreements
that we plan to move forward to expedite
and we also want to keep on
having context and consultations at the
highest level
to promote the cooperation between
russia and armenia
and russia has always been the main
economical partner of armenia and the
bilateral traitor nova is high during
this economic
instability during this pandemic even
despite
the drop in the
general economic activity so we were
happy to
keep up the tempo of our relations and
during these restrictions we
continued to
exchange cargos and to strengthen our
trade and
cooperation agreement and mr lavrov has
already mentioned
that we are planning to find
ways to organize a regular meeting of
the russian armenian intergovernmental
committee which is one of the
most important platforms for our
economic cooperation
our countries has been successfully
cooperating
in the international forums and armenia
as part of the eurasian economic union
recently in your event the inter
governmental committee
has met and we adhere to
the efforts applied to continue
to develop this organization
that we are part of and that has
affects positively the lives of our
citizens
we continue to cut rate and military
technical cooperation
it's a strategical direction it's one of
our priorities
one of the priorities of our bilateral
agenda
we continue to
as part of it and the csto as well
because we think an
important part of the stability we could
go on and on talking about the russian
armenian relations and about individual
areas of its relations but as you
understand that
today we paid
special attention on the developments
and the situation that has become
a real threat for the entire region
fellow countrymen has faced existential
threat
that has been ongoing for several
decades starting from the 27th
of september and it's still continuing
the military authority so authority
budget
started a large scale aggression against
the people of nagorno-karabakh and they
openly demonstrate
their true values of the military
resolution of the nagorno-karabakh
conflict and
to eliminate
the armenian population and
is no difference with the military
actions and peaceful actions
and they want to attack first of all the
civilians and during this military
aggression azerbaijani forces attacked
more than
120 civilian asides
including
settlements of the like stephen occurred
and other cities at the armed forces of
attorney and
ignored their duties on the protection
of the civilians
and the fact that there is no military
sites
near the attack size proves that the
azerbaijani forces are behind these
crimes and the use of aviation
including the support of the turkish
aviation
the use of the unmanned flying vehicles
heavy artillery
and cell launchers and tanks there are a
lot of victims
among the population among the civilians
because of the
other bajani use of such ammunition
as a result on 10th of october
um
because of the actions of the
azerbaijani forces other forces
uh that support them 23 civilians died
and 81 citizens were heavily wounded
and the people had to relocate to other
settlements and to other towns of
nagorno-karabakh some of them
had to settle down in the armenia huge
damage was done to the
civ infrastructure and to the
residential buildings almost 6 000
houses shops and other buildings were
damaged or destroyed
960 infrastructure sites
production infrastructure of energy
infrastructure bridges schools
kindergartens
the community centers and factories were
completely
destroyed and 25 energy infrastructure
sites and the power lines across the
country were destroyed
the power plants were seriously severely
damaged or destroyed and the
sites of the religious cult were also
destroyed on
holy savior which is an important
cultural and religious symbol of
artsakh as a result of this
civilians suffered including the media
representatives during this period media
representatives were also
have also become targets of the attacks
there were cases of the serious injuries
and bones
from the media representatives both
armenian journalists and international
journalists and representatives
of uh russian media
was uh wounded quite severely during the
second
attack on the territory where the
cathedral of the holy savior is located
i have given you the details of the
situation
which serves as the evidence that
there is an existential threat that has
we have been talking about for decades
for the people of arza uh the people of
our
faith for the decades and it's
aggravated by two negative factors
at this stage in particular is the
direct
participation of turkey that deploys
terrorists and exists in the region and
the militants
jihadists and terrorists are widely used
by turkey
to promote the interests of the current
turkish authorities
for the neighboring regions and
deployment of the
foreign militants from syria and libya
is not
only carbureted by
a number of sources and evidence and the
help from the turkish
armed theories has become a platform
platform to extend the influence of
turkey in this region
and this policy of promoting and helping
and supporting the terrorist
organizations by trading corridors to
access the transcaucasian region serves
as an evidence of this terrorist
activity and we must stop
the hostilities and uh russia plays an
important part
in this i would like to emphasize the
importance of the
joint statement that we have reached two
days ago once again i would like to
thank
for the active part for the
participation of
russia and personally vladimir putin and
also for the active work that has been
carried out
to i would like to extend this
gratitude to mr lavrov because of this
joint work we have managed to reach the
joint statement
that aimed at
stopping all the hostilities
and aimed at reaching
truth unfortunately as of now
we can't say that we have reached a
significant level of the ceasefire
thereby china does not carry on
said judaism and under a ceasefire
agreement i would like
to emphasize the importance of this
mechanism
that will allow us to reach the
ceasefire
only after the facilities are over
we can move on effectively regarding
all the issues armenia has always been
advocate of uh peaceful resolution of
nagorno-karabakh conflict by
talks and negotiations and we will
continue
to adhere to this principle in our work
mr lavrov
has said that today and tomorrow i will
have meetings with
my counterparts with the code chairman
so we will continue working in this
regard but i would like to emphasize
one more time that it was a heavy blow
to the peaceful approaches by all these
actions on behalf of azerbaijan
and we cannot help but taking
into consideration the negative impact
that it had
safety and security for the people of
ours and we will continue to do
everything we can to guarantee
all the rights to the people of arctic
to
cleanse the region of terrorists and to
cleanse
the region of all possible negative
influence once again i would like to
thank you mr lover for
the cardio welcome and for a very
constructive
and fruitful negotiations
throughout the day we are going to have
more talks and more negotiations
i would like to thank you one more time
for your personal
input into strengthening the cooperation
between russia and armenia and uh
and strengthening of our alliance
thank you very much any questions please
do you recall there's a question to mr
lavrov
after this large-scale aggression of
adorable gen
against artsakh that has been
accompanied by
the intentional targeting of the
civilian objects and of infrastructure
objects
when it was bombarded as mr ministries
said so many cities were destroyed so
many
objects were destroyed so how the
peaceful process can be developed what
are the possible solutions what are the
possible options or we will go to
different directions
introductory remarks we said that we
stand by the joint statement that we
made in support of the ceasefire
the ceasefire to be
immediately on humanitarian grounds
should be swapped should be collected
and the political process should be
renewed under the auspices
of the boise miss group
there are all the parameters there in
place that's what
we believe in we in armenia if someone
wants to go
in a different direction well who where
please russian 24. hello
keeping in mind what happened in the
last days when both parties are blaming
each other
and violating ceasefire so what could be
this verification mechanism
that will allow to establish the
ceasefire regime on the ground and what
can you
reply to the flames of armenian the
ceasefire violation and mr lavrov what
could be the major role in waiting for
all of russia
so that we could fail fully implement
the agreements
reached uh the 12th october
regarding the verification mechanism at
the moment
i would prefer to be a little bit more
cautious
uh because we are holding consultations
regarding this matters
based on what has been expressed in our
joint statement our priority today is
reaching a ceasefire and establishing
verification mechanisms
so we have this situation today when we
haven't reached the level where we can
switch
move to work on the first
uh matter on the statements so we are
trying to attract the red cross
organization on to this process
use russia as a mediator in this sense
so that we could find a mechanism where
we could start
actually working on that and co-chairs
are also
attracted to this work used in this work
so that we could start this work
and establish the reliable groundwork
to achieve reliable ceasefires so that
we could start working on humanitarian
agents if we can't extend the truth
and it will continue having negative
influence on all the other
matters so keeping and strengthening
these truths
is a challenge to us is a priority to us
that's why the
verification mechanisms are very
important we have been talking about
that on a number of occasions
if there are any accusations against
armenia or against nagorno-karabakh we
keep saying
that it's high time
we introduced the verification mechanism
but there were a lot of
offers and suggestions regarding that we
should have done that
long time ago but that's not up to
romania or
nagornikarpa we didn't refuse that
azerbaijan refused to
introduce the verification mechanism so
i'm not agreed to accept any accusations
against
armenia or nagorno-karabakh in the
context of what is happening today
armenia has always been current or of
the safety of nagorno-karabakh there is
no other system
that plays up there and for
nagorno-karabakh
is uh this is a question of
their existence so it's more than a
reality to them now keeping in mind what
is happening on the ground
today thank you i haven't missed any of
your questions
haven't i think you've said it all
and i want to say that therification
mechanism
as a concept is a very key system
and it certainly is part of the
conversations
that presidents of heads of russia or
minister bhajan
have been having they discussed
verification indeed
which is how on the ground the cs5
might be monitored and controlled
the joint statement that was announced
a couple of days ago read that
the work on the future control and
verification mechanisms
will be worked out later as an addition
to the ceasefire when the standard
situation
is indeed an acute one
and we know that this problem
where the prisoners is also
he
sensitive situation we should be
quite active we should not be stalling
we should
not be dragging out this issue for too
long we
would like to thank the international
red cross
committee for their readiness to
join their efforts with us as soon as
the situation on the ground is
stabilized
as for future russia's involvement in
the settlement
i can tell you that we will be working
on that track
very very much
and we will do that both as the
co-chairman of the
voice siemens group and as a strategic
partner to our neighbors
i think that our
loan hours that we spend on talks
on arranging everything within the
ceasefire
it will not come to not i hope that
it will yield real improvement to the
situation on the ground
in the immediate future we all are
very much invested in seeing that happen
splitting agency please and good
afternoon senior chicago sputnik agency
a question to build ministry president
of azerbaijan ali
has said that turkey must play more
active role in settling the counseling
both in the means group and in other
reports
and with this in mind do you think that
the more active role played by turkey
and the means
obviously group could help to promote
the
peaceful settlement and how and can we
talk about any other new forms if the
joint statement after the moscow talks
and armenia confirmed their adherence to
the to this uh format
and the question for mr lavrov does
russia
keep staying contact with turkey
regarding this issue and how could you
describe the turkish position
you're absolutely right and i think that
essentially you've answered your own
question
we believe that there is no alternative
to talks to negotiations
this is the only way to do that i mean
through the means
group of the osce this is a group of
nations
which work hard on this issue it
delegated the
authority of the talks of the
remediation to three co-chairmen
which are russia the united states and
france
and
they all show that there is overwhelming
support
towards these three chairmen and we
together with our
american and french colleagues are
working hard to
make progress on this track
are represented by their respective
officials they're here in moscow
and last
so when we say that we confirmed the
fact that there is no alternative to the
negotiations and this is the only format
which
we should rely on here it means that we
are not alone here
we will continue supporting political
settlement based on the principles which
have been
worked out with the help of the
co-chairman all of them
i think this is a very exhaustive answer
to your question
and i'd like to highlight the following
president ali
welcomed the moscow agreement
during our time at night when we were
burning midnight oil
for hours discussing the ceasefire
i contacted the foreign minister of
turkey
mr chushuglu informing him that we hope
that turkey would support our efforts
and on sunday we had another telephone
conversation which
resulted in turkey supporting the moscow
format
of talks so now it all
boils down to seeing progress on the
ground and that's what we are working
on right now
i can only add that it's true the
support to the current forum has been
expressed in the
joint statement that has been made on
the 10th of october
so the
futures of the means group of the oec is
the only effective
format to resettlement
it has never caused any doubts
and especially now it doesn't cause any
doubt and we will continue to work
actively
within this format
and we have already said that we are
going to stay in contact uh you
understand that what is
happening now on the ground what is
happening now in the courtney carrera
this uh expressed aggression and the
state that nakano kharada
is in now so has uh impact seriously
affects seriously the way we work now
because our position has always been
that there is no
alternative to the israel settlement
keith azerbaijan chose the way of using
force
as a method of
reaching certain conditions forcing
certain conditions
then there will be no peaceful
settlement and there will be no peace
and the region and this
method was always reduced so
that what we should be working on and
that's
our understanding and that's where we
are going to go with the culture it says
for that
rule by turkey i'm sorry but the active
role of hurricane now is
deploying militants to our region and
having active military support for
azerbaijan
and you should understand that it can't
be welcomed in
any way it's kind of active real thank
you
thank you so much and goodbye
uh-huh
cheers
um
online
you